c'était la fête dans les tribunes du
stade mob auront de versailles dans le
cadre de la trêve internationale la
guinée les comores se sont affrontés ce
samedi en match amical
une rencontre inédite sur cette pelouse
qui a plutôt l'habitude de voir évoluer
des équipes de nationale 3 c'est festif
ça fait vraiment plaisir de voir de voir
le stade et les tribunes pleines et une
ambiance chaleureuse
voilà qui les gens qui viennent
supporter leur sélection ça fait
vraiment c'est vraiment sympa le rendez
vous a attiré des milliers de supporters
venus pour encourager leurs protégés et
surtout analyser le niveau de jeu des
deux équipes en pleine préparation en
vue des éliminatoires de la prochaine
coupe d'afrique des nations jouent en
ile de france y joue plutôt souvent
en espagne où
en afrique nous sommes venus de
bruxelles uniquement pour ce match tant
c'est la patrie ça n'a pas de prix on a
près à n'importe quelle distance ou
venez le booster pour la petite histoire
les comores l'ont emporté sur la plus
petite des marges sur le score de 1 but
à 0 vu le succès rencontré pour cette
affiche la ville de versailles n'exclut
pas d'organiser d'autres rencontres
internationales dans les prochaines
années
[Musique]